welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity tonight we have yet another
Democratic scandal to bring you Fox News
has confirmed that Democratic
congressman Bob Brady is being
investigated by the FBI for his
potentially unlawful involvement in his
scheme to pay his 2012 primary opponents
90 thousand dollars to drop out of the
race Brady has yet to be charged but the
FBI has executed a search warrant of the
congressman's AOL email accounts with
probable cause to believe that he
committed election law violations
joining us now with more is Salem radio
nationally syndicated host Larry elder
and Fox News contributor Kevin Jackson
are a good evening gentlemen I must tell
you that I know someone who years ago
offered a job to a primary opponents in
a state assembly race in New York and as
a result of that he was indicted and he
ended up going to jail now if it is true
that Brady did this what should happen
to him Larry he should go to jail of
course but Judge this is about
Philadelphia this is one of the most
corrupt cities in the country you have
the the DA who's just been indicted on
23 counts of corruption you have the
majority of the traffic cops that have
been convicted of charges they've got
people on City Council on tape
discussing bribes it's one of the most
corrupt cities in America so I suspect
the congressman is just following the
the the role models who preceded him
well and Kevin your take on this I think
it's funny that we have this number
remember William Jefferson forget his I
think his name was William Jefferson the
black guy who had $90,000 in his
refrigerator yes it was in his freezer
freezer yeah right in his freezer is
ninety thousand ago anyway right cold
cash there's ninety thousand a going
rate for slavery today you know the
interesting part of this story to me
Janine and Larry can certainly relate we
have a white congressman who
wants his black counterpart the guy's
gonna run against him not to do it so he
pays him off with a ninety thousand it
was african-american that's my point
that the gentleman the judge that was
paid off happens to be a black guy
so that's democrat politics if I can't
beat the guy you know what I'll do I'll
just pay him off this harkens back and I
know this is gonna really make some
liberals mad but this harkens back to
the days of slavery nineteen thousand
dollars is a going rate for it well I
mean it's true true it's hard
oh I'm just saying it that's the going
rate and here's here's the problem the
the judge who thinks he's gonna run for
this office he probably thought I'm
doing this on behalf of black people so
what he said all the blacks who invested
in his in his race was I'm willing to
sell you out for ninety thousand dollars
to pay off my campaign fees and have a
little chump change left over all right
let's talk about the fact that it seems
like so many Democrats are in trouble
right now
you know and and and at the same time it
appears that a lot of the criticism that
was initially waged against or aimed at
Democrats whether it's Donna Brazile or
you know this New York Times writer who
says you know Al Franken's got to resign
and then the next day she says I'm
changing my mind is there a concern on
the part of those Democrats that the
more they talk about corruption by the
Democrats whether it's sexual harassment
or buying seeds that they're going to
lose their politics and their political
power in Washington well what's happened
is that the Democrats have been exposed
as hypocrites on the issue of sexual
harassment you have Bill Clinton who was
credibly accused by three women
according to a book called no one left
to lie to of rape you have Hillary who
has credibly accused by Juanita
Broderick of intimidating an alleged
rape survivor and they got a pass and
it's not going to happen anymore and in
Philadelphia as I mentioned one of the
most corrupt cities in the country they
had an 11 term congressman just indicted
and charged and thrown out of office and
the city is is Democrat Republican 7 to
1 a completely Democratic City totally
they can do whatever they want and I
mentioned they had all these council
persons on tape nobody got charged okay
but it's incredible
it is incredible but what what is
incredible to me right now is that
initially there was Kirsten Gillibrand
from New York and she's like shame on
Bill Clinton we should have done
something about it
and then when she's asked whether or not
Al Franken should resign she won't
answer the question right Donna Brazile
comes out and she says you know this is
horrible what the Clintons did was
horrible and then all of a sudden it
seems that she's now trying to make nice
with the Clintons there is this all of a
sudden there's this change in the by the
Democrats where they are not as critical
of Democrats who are violating the any
moral code or laws because it appears
that it looks like their power base is
being affected judge they don't know
what to do that's their problem see what
conservatives if these things happen we
react we don't care who the person is if
Donald Trump had done what Al Franken or
some of these other people had done we
would have reacted identically the same
our moral core stays complete
it's a Larry's point not only are the
Democrats bad when it comes to the issue
of sexual harassment they're bad on
every other policy look at their policy
on immigration you can find 50
high-level Democrats who said we need to
secure the borders for all the reasons
that Donald Trump says you can find 50
high-level Democrats during the time of
Obama that said we need to look at our
Muslim refugee resettlement program and
so on and so forth all they care about
is who's in power and so right now
they're living on the muscle-memory
they don't know do the Clintons still
have power or do they not and that's
what you're seeing they don't know for
sure well but but but but what it does
seem like Larry and and and you can feed
off of that one but it does seem that
the Clinton Power has as dissipated but
at the same time there's a little
reluctance to go all the way you
couldn't be that if a senator resigns
like Al Franken that maybe you know if
there is a Republican governor the
Republican governor gets to a point that
this is not about women it's not about
their morale
or it's about rank politics it's about
power and money and it has nothing to do
with with a moral compass well as Kevin
pointed out the Democrats don't know
what to do judge the the revelations of
Harvey Weinstein so blatant they can no
longer ignore them if you're going to go
after a judge roar more how come you
didn't go after Bill Clinton how come he
didn't go after Hillary how come you
haven't gone after Al Franken how can
you even gone after John Conyers they
are now caught in their hypocrisy and
recall after Kathleen Willey claimed
that she was groped by Bill Clinton a
feminist named Gloria Steinem wrote a
column and said even if you believe what
Kathleen Willey said is true that's not
sexual harassment because Bill Clinton
stopped after he was told to stop are
you kidding me this is the pretzel into
which the left twisted themselves to
defend the Clintons and now the chickens
have come home to roost and and how is
that going to impact the 28 teams Kevin
they're gonna get crushed you know
what's funny every time I hear these
left is they talked about the wins that
they just recently had with the
governors which we're expected wins but
they've not they've learned no lessons
and Larry's pointing out the hypocrisy
we do it every day on our radio shows
and you name it but the Democrats don't
learn and then the problem they're
having judge is they still don't
understand where the power structure is
so they're still not trying to weed out
or do the Clintons still have power does
Obama have any power in fact there's the
I heard they're going to bring Bill
Clinton out to campaign somebody wants
Clinton to campaign in 2018 the Clintons
are in around Obama and by the way
Brazil went after Obama today I mean it
just keeps going they don't they don't
know who they are
Bill Clinton is politically Bill Clinton
is dead man walking he's post now they
can no longer ignore allegations made by
juanita project and more importantly
judge Hillary still never been asked to
my knowledge did you or did you not
verbally intimidate this alleged rape
survivor and wanita question well you
know why they're not asking for that
question because she's still trying to
figure out why she lost in 2016
she came
with another excuse today I can't keep
track of it and you know what I keep
telling her just go back in the woods
Hilary enough one other quick point so
why aren't they asking Barack Obama to
campaign that's what Donna Brazile is
essentially saying she you know it's
funny she gave him credit for saving
America but she won't bring him out to
campaign and she explained he lost all
these seats the Democrats have nothing
this is a fun time for conservatives
enjoy people yep he lost all the seats
and he left the DNC broke and you're
right all right Larry Kevin thanks for
being with us